nous sommes ici dans l'hémicycle et pas
sur une de vos vidéos youtube vous
pouvez exprimer votre avis mais pas
considérer que nous serions responsables
des virus ou des morts s'il vous plaît
gardez au moins le peu de décence qui
vous reste
[Musique]
la vérité c'est que le virus ce ne
n'était pas de votre faute
mais désormais ça les salles et un peu
vous avez refusé que le bac ça soit bien
public mondial
vous choisissez de vous soumettre à la
pénurie vous décidé de prolonger tunnel
quoi qu'il en coûte
[Musique]
quand vous avez sanofi qui produit des
laboratoires axa pour des laboratoires
concurrents
pourquoi qu'il est tombé du ciel
pourquoi que sanofi regarder une vidéo
youtube de monsieur rufin et s'est dit
ah là là va produire des vaccins
étrangers c'est pas comme ça que ça
marcherait vraie vie monsieur leur faim
la vraie vie c'est être responsable et
la responsabilité ça vous a compensé
vous êtes parlementaire
[Musique]
or monsieur rufin ça suffit ça suffit
monsieur rufin ça suffit vos
interpellations
chaque fois vous organisez le spectacle
vous voulez faire remarquer vos rares
présences
croyez bien que ce n'est pas votre
honneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant une semaine durant son mandat
même pendant une semaine depuis qu'il
est élu à l'assemblée ça fait maintenant
maintenant un gros gros paquet d'années
est ce qu'une seule fois il est
intervenu sur autant de dossiers
différents
devez-vous terme sur fin à la base sur
les bancs à gauche voilà je mets au défi
monsieur opérant pas lui envoyer un
courrier en ce sens sur son travail à
lui à l'assemblée et le travail du
groupe en marche à l'assemblée